Speaker 1: s coming out of the House of Representatives.
Nancy Pelosi now says that the House of Representatives
is indeed going to move forward on an assault
weapons ban.
There was previously an assault weapons ban
that ran from 1994 to 2004 in the United States.
And we will talk about that in a moment.
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi says House
Democrats will soon consider legislation banning
military style, quote, assault weapons, marking
the most aggressive response from Congress
to date following last week's shooting massacre
at a Texas elementary school.
House Democratic leaders have already scheduled
to vote next week on so-called red flag legislation
designed to keep weapons from potentially
violent people.
The House Judiciary Committee is meeting in
an emergency session to mark up a slate of
eight additional anti-gun violence bills,
including proposals to ban high capacity magazines
and raise the age for purchasing certain semiautomatic
rifles.
I am in favor of all of this and also recognize
that it is not enough, and we're going to
get back to that.
Now, on the question of whether mass shootings
went down during the assault weapons ban and
then went back up after it has been examined
by PolitiFact and it has been found to be
mostly true.
Joe Biden said when we passed the assault
weapons ban, mass shootings went down.
When the law expired, mass shootings tripled.
PolitiFact has ruled that is mostly true.
There explanation is let me find it here.
There are numbers that back Biden up.
A 2019 study out of NYU School of Medicine
found mass shooting deaths involving assault
weapons fell slightly in the decade of the
federal assault weapon ban and then rose dramatically
in the decade that followed.
While other researchers said the decline was
too small to draw firm conclusions, there's
no debate that the pace and deadliness of
shootings went up after the ban ended.
Beyond assault weapons, more recent work points
to the threat posed by large capacity magazines,
which the 1994 law also restricted.
That is also a factor with the same guns but
without the large capacity magazines.
You would also see less, less death.
So if you go back to last week, I had my segment
where I laid out it was either ten or 11 specific
ideas on gun safety.
And in that list I included limiting certain
firearms to 25 plus some.
Some are saying 21 plus I say 25 plus requiring
mandatory gun insurance, requiring more extensive
training and relicensing a mandatory waiting
period of, of course, reducing the ability
to have the high capacity magazines, a mandatory
initial and periodic mental health evaluations
requiring 2 to 3 letters from adults in the
community, saying, I have no concerns about
this individual under age 25 having firearms.
I gave a long list, but we actually need to
do more than that.
And of course, Republicans are going to oppose
this.
I say that Democrats, in conjunction with
this bill to ban assault weapons again, which
will it pass in the Senate?
Rob Probably not.
Quite frankly, unfortunately, they should
call the bluff of the Republicans saying,
well, this is a mental health issue, proposed
mental health legislation as well.
Now, of course, part of that is red flag laws,
which would prevent individuals flagged for
concerning behavior and diagnoses from it,
would prevent them from getting weapons.
But do something more significant require
require an initial mental health eval as well
as periodic ones.
Now, I know a lot of people have raised the
question.
Let's say you do that, David.
What are you looking for?
Is it just a psychiatrist meets with everybody
and then evaluates for what what conditions
prevent you from getting a gun?
How does anxiety compare with borderline personality
disorder compare with if you've had a psychotic
episode?
Well, you've got to figure that out.
The fact that it's complicated can't be a
reason not to do it.
I concede it's complicated, but it absolutely
needs to be done.
If all of these things were in place when
it came to the shooter in Texas, can't buy
the weapons he bought because he's under age
25.
Even to get a handgun needs to have letters
from the community.
Supposedly members in the community were already
some were already concerned about this individual.
Limits on high capacity magazines waiting
period, mandatory insurance which would have
made it more expensive and maybe dissuaded,
although he reportedly spent a bunch of money
on the guns.
Those things at least had the chance, the
chance of impacting that individual's ability
to get those firearms and those bullets and
to kill as many people.
Could he have ended up killing five with a
couple of handguns?
Yes, absolutely.
But as tragic as those five deaths would be,
would we prefer five instead of 20?
I mean, I would I would.
So I would like to see Democrats not only
push for the assault weapons ban, propose
some mental health legislation to Republicans,
including increased funding as well.
At the state level, they don't want it.
Many states didn't even do the Medicare the
Medicaid expansion that was part of Obamacare,
which would have increased access as well.
So make them put up or shut up, make them
go on record as opposing the mental health
legislation.
They're the ones claiming that's the first
thing to look at.
Well, look at it.
But also look at guns.
And we've got to look at a lot of other things.
I am sure I will get many questions on this
topic on our upcoming town hall.
That will be Tuesday, June 14th at 6 p.m.
Eastern, streaming live on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel.
That's the other YouTube channel.
Make sure you're subscribed there for free.
And I look forward to speaking to lots of
you then.
The David Pakman show is a community supported
independent media program.
You can sign up at join Pacman dot com and
in fact I encourage you to do so.
You can use the new coupon code.
Big voting 22.
Big voting 22 to get a massive discount and
also to do a really great thing supporting
independent media.
Join Packman dot com is the place to do it.
Let's hear from some people in the audience.
We take calls on the Friday show via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash Discord.
Let's start today with Nevin from Tennessee.
Nevin, welcome to the show.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I had to question first
of all.
Speaker 1: There's something there's something
that just banged in the background.
You said you have to question.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Yes.
Okay.
So firstly, do you think that progressive
economic reforms such as universal healthcare,
tuition forgiveness, etc. can be accomplished
without a big economic depression, such as
for the New Deal during FDR.
Speaker 1: You said, can can we avoid an economic
depression through programs like the New Deal?
Speaker 2: Yes.
Like universal health care or news programs?
Like stuff like that.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, generally speaking, government spending
that is carefully thought, carefully conceived
to be economically stimulative through what
we call demand side stimulus is a good way
to both do good things for the people and
also to help the economy.
The devil is in the details of the programs
and the spending.
Speaker 2: Well, okay.
And I'd also like to ask you, what can liberals
like myself do in our house?
Speaker 1: Did you say for the progressive
cause?
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: Well, get involved in local races
at some level, even in southern red states.
Is there an opportunity to replace a right
wing state rep or state senator with someone
more progressive?
Is there an opportunity to get involved in
a school board?
There's lots of local opportunities and also
you can still phone bank for any race across
the country that you want.
So like, imagine that you're in Alabama and
there's no likely Democratic Senate challenger
in Alabama.
You can phone bank for Fetterman in Pennsylvania.
Right, or you can whatever.
So there's there's no shortage of ways to
get involved.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
That's all.
Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Nevin, I have to ask, where are
you calling from?
The noise in the background is wild.
Speaker 2: I'm on a bus ride.
Speaker 1: Oh, you're on a bus right now?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Do people around, you know you're
on The David Pakman Show.
Speaker 2: They probably don't know what it
is.
Speaker 1: They don't know.
All right, Evan, thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: You're welcome.
All right.
Speaker 1: Nevin Nevin from thank you, Nevin
from a bus in Tennessee.
That is something else.
I don't know that we've ever had a call from
a bus necessarily.